foreign
looking into the question of the
evolution of farming in leafcutter ants
and what the comparisons are if any uh
to the evolution of farming in humans
and one of the comparisons is well
humans uh
originated farming many many times
across the world in fact in China alone
there are two different evolutions of
farming there's at least
there's at least one origin in Europe
maybe more a couple in the new world
several
um several all over the world but it's
always it seems within like about 10 to
12 000 years ago 12 000 years ago is
about as far back as we think farming
goes there was some uh domestication
happening before then but agriculture is
10 12 000 years ago in each of the
places that it happens independently
whereas ants
started farming oh 50 million years ago
they've had a bit of a head start on
they definitely thought of it they
definitely well they definitely yes I
funny of course to say it that way but
of course one of the big differences you
know one of the reasons that we have
been able to you know catch up and in
some ways you might say surpass them in
terms of the diversity that we have uh
employed our farming uh with is that of
course for them presumably it's entirely
genetic right they they're they're
they're they're little robots uh running
around doing their thing and it's
working for them and it's working for
the fungus that they are um farming
on the leaves that they are cutting and
carrying and growing the fungus on a
substrate but they are not uh learning
in real time right to you know how how
to farm better or different things or
anything and so there's a lot of course
to be said about about
this but there was one paragraph and
this really remarkable paper a really
long like a monograph in um
in a book called insect fungal
associations ecology and evolution a
piece by schultzedal from 2005 is when
this book was published called
reciprocal illumination a comparison of
agriculture in humans and so the
comparison is okay we have these 18 ants
who've been farming for 50 million years
50 million years five zero million years
and humans who've been farming for 10 to
12 000 years and uh what you know what
are some of the comparisons uh so so
question yeah
um are in this are you going to describe
that farming uh or should we do that in
advance of you reading this go for it
um so uh the the basics of the farming
involve the removal of pieces you've
undoubtedly seen pictures of ants which
have cut a kind of fingernail-shaped
piece of a leaf they do this from canopy
trees they bring them one piece at a
time in large numbers down into to an
underground cavity where they grow a
fungus which is uniquely adapted to this
Association it grows on the leaves
because the ants are animals they
actually do not for whatever reason have
the chemical capacity to break down the
leaves directly fungus for whatever
reason are much better at uh Advanced
Feats of organic chemistry and they are
able to break down the cellulose and
other components of the leaves and so
essentially the ants facilitate the
growth of the fungus and they eat the
fungus and uh this is clearly
mutualistic interaction with many
fascinating offshoots and other features
indeed and there are there are many
stages of agriculture in these ants the
leaf Cutters being you know by our
estimation with our anthropomorphic lens
on it the Pinnacle of atyne Agriculture
of ant agriculture but there are there
are many stages that are you know less
tightly symbiotic there are pathogens
that are also co-evolved with you know
with this fungus ant coevolution so you
know it's it's just
story just goes more and more amazing
the deeper you go but this is not going
to be that that story here the paragraph
I want to read from this paper Schultz
at all 2005 and I'll have you show my
screen when I'm when I'm ready to read
it here
just talks about the question of
um where who has the control so with
humans
we imagine that okay well we're the
farmers therefore you know the the crops
that we have domesticated be they plant
or animal or in some cases fungus or
clearly under our control we are the
Masters and you can similarly look at
ants and guess the same thing
and there's some evidence with regard to
the ants given what the what we can tell
50 million years is a long time for this
Association to be happening so it's hard
to know it's impossible to know exactly
what the ants 50 million years ago who
were not farming look like and what
they're eating but all evidence suggests
that they were basically eating
arthropods insects live and dead and the
advantages to the fungus and to the ants
for going into this sort of forming
relationship
um see it seems like some evidence that
actually the fungus might have had more
of a drive to end up being in this
association with the ants than the ants
did which raises questions about control
I mean you know who's actually in
control here and when you think you see
a system in which one or the other
person organism system whatever it is
it's like control maybe look more
closely look from a different angle and
find that actually control has a lot of
different levers and a lot of different
ways of manifesting itself so let's go
with this uh this paragraph here and
I'll just put it on the screen so people
can read along that did not work
and if it doesn't it doesn't work hold
on let's try one more time got that
plugged in it is plugged in still
nope it's very blue okay well I'm going
to go ahead and unplug that so that I do
not risk my computer suddenly showing up
uh and I will just read it off the
screen and I'll link to uh a link to
this in the show notes again from
Schultz at all 2005.
we suspect that most readers will resist
our suggestion that human
agriculturalists were once under the
partial control of their
proto-domesticates during the early
evolutionary process that ultimately led
to human agriculture
human intuition suggests that we are not
under the control of the cabbages and
tomatoes that we plant in our backyards
the cabbages cannot facultatively escape
from our Gardens and from their
inevitable Destinies of death in our
kitchens and that cabbages have not
enslaved us to labor on their
evolutionary behalf
human intuition can be misleading
however we know for example that human
symbiones can sometimes induce profound
behavioral changes in humans that
benefit the symbiont the rabies virus
induces drastic aggressive behavior to
facilitate its spread to new potential
hosts and coca plants induce in humans
of physical addiction and a craving for
more coca which requires the cultivation
of more coca plants
though seemingly far-fetched and in
conflict with our intuitions we can at
this point rule out similar
manipulations during the
pre-agricultural evolution of humans a
stage when humans began to assemble the
behavioral repertoires that ultimately
led to agricultural systems Guided by
human planning and intentional
experimentation
this
I wanted to just put out there
for people who have not
even farming much thought give an ant
farming much thought and agriculture
much thought as a way as a different way
in
to being able to question
of any system that you think you
understand
who is actually
pulling the strings who's actually
calling the shots
um yeah I want to uh there's one thing
in that paragraph that I find troubling
the use of rabies as an example right
after the term symbi app because it's
clearly not in my aunt yep
um and so you know
I think it's a very worthy explanation
so symbiant it's not
um but is it um is it able to exert a
behavioral influence on us of course it
is of course and you know the case of uh
Coca is a better example where it is
likely a mutualism
um and there are many examples of uh
human mutualisms there are plants which
are only known from Human cultivation
which suggests that uh an ancestor uh
changed radically in order to partner
with humans
um what are you thinking uh Salvia
um
so there's lots of salvias but the
Salvia that is used
um as a psychoactive yeah gen uh in
central Mexico is only known from The
Gardens of the the population that
utilizes its fascinating uh plant
um there is a a euphorb in Madagascar
which is only known from Gardens it's
not clear whether that's a mutualism or
whether it's simply gone extinct in the
wild and been preserved by people but in
any case there there are a number of
examples
and
I do think you know evolutionarily I
would say the real question
effectively what you have to realize is
that a mutualism tends to start as a
parasitism and a parasitism that does
not harm but in fact in some indirect
way helps the creature being parasitized
is almost immediately immutualism and
because the creature that is being
parasitized but oh it ends up being in
that positive thing then becomes
augmented to facilitate this interaction
and you know if you think about the the
the classic case of something like a
hummingbird
um you know taking nectar and
transporting pollen for a flower to
which it is adapted
it seems like oh they're cooperating but
of course the hummingbird is truly
indifferent to the well-being of the
plant
um at least first order and at least
first order at least first order and the
plant is indifferent to the hummingbird
they are each taking advantage of each
other and because they are both getting
a benefit that outweighs the cost that
they are paying we say oh it's a
cooperation and there's nothing wrong
with that in fact well the tight of the
cooperation the tighter the need right
right yes so I mean this this will be
the thing that maybe isn't obvious to
people who haven't considered for
instance a hummingbird plant affiliation
which is that you know the more
tight the for instance Corolla of the
flower is the particular recurve nature
decrimp nature can't remember which is
which of the hummingbird's beak uh the
the more both of those species actually
depend on the other in order to make it
into the future right have their genes
make it into the future and they're you
know there's a lot of nuance here it can
be that the plant is uh obligate with
respect to what pollinator it needs and
that the pollinator might be a
generalist in some cases there can be
cases where the relationship is obligate
on both sides but in any case
at some point where a mutualism has
occurred we are effectively defining the
mutualism based on the fact that both
parties are benefiting from what might
otherwise be a one-way parasitism but
that is in some sense our projection
onto it
and in any case you know it's clear that
these ants uh and actually I wish we did
have the ability to show your screen you
could show some pictures of this but
these plants are a major
force uh in these plants these ants okay
Major Force in the habitats where they
are
um doing their farming they're actually
significantly altering the amount of
photosynthetic capacity of the trees
that they're utilizing
um and so that they're they're
tremendously powerful ecological
phenomenon and
um what that also means is that this
huge amount of productivity that the
that the trees were producing that the
ants had no access to directly they have
found a way to access it through What
Might Have Been a parasite on their
ancestors but it turned out to be
beneficial right in other words
um you know you could imagine a fungus
growing inside I have no idea if this is
the proposed mechanism but you know that
there might have been a fungus growing
inside the effectively Caverns that
these animals created maybe it was
growing on arthropods maybe it was was
you know I I'm not sure what it was and
you can imagine maybe ants had uh you
know tunneled into some place where
there was Leaf matter or something and
some fungus is breaking down the leaves
you could see how you could get to a
place where actually feeding the fungus
would uh emerge from The Accidental fact
of a fungus
growing on on cellulose
um but at the point that we arrived
currently and we look at this highly uh
interwoven set of adaptations right you
have a fungus that can't grow without
the ants you've got ants that are
utterly dependent on the fungus that
you've got behaviors in which that's
true Aegis and I had not said that
um at at this point the fungus that the
ants are farming is obligately in
association with ant fungiculture it
does not exist outside of the ant
fungiculture which is remarkable it is
remarkable and so then that leads to
this consideration right I'm
always troubled by people's sense that
um you know vegetarianism is a favor to
the creatures
that we eat it is no such thing
especially for the creatures that we
cultivate in large numbers right
chickens are far better off uh
evolutionarily than their jungle fowl
ancestors cows are far better off than
their wild relatives just by virtue of
the amount of control that humans exert
on the ecosystem and so although it's
counterintuitive to us so
the place that you will get dried for
saying that is that you haven't defined
better off you are talking about
evolutionarily better off
individuals might also be but not in a
factory farming situation oh and this
that is the place where I I would argue
that the harm to the individual animals
at the level of suffering is so great
that even though evolutionarily even the
factory farmed animals are certainly in
a better position that morally we are
obligated to
um to confront that problem and to end
that practice but
you know just as you know we're all
gonna die
it does not no I swear it's true
um that does not cause you it does not
invalidate your life right it does not
make you not want to live while you're
here likewise an animal that is going to
be slaughtered for food is not you know
a
non-animal it's an animal with a known
end of its life just as a salmon uh
Pacific salmon has a known end of its
life right after it reproduces
um so anyway the point is we need to
rethink these things because from the
you know
perspective of the organisms in question
the interests are not intuitively
obvious to us humans well I think I
think one of the pieces you didn't say
there is that um most of our
domesticated
food animals
most of those individuals if not all of
those individuals would not exist but
for the fact of our having domesticated
them so the fact that they will die in
service of being eaten by humans
basically starts starts the analysis too
late if you really if you're concerned
about the lifespan of the individual
consider that the individual never would
have existed at all never would have
existed at all
yep and that that's exactly it
um and
um so anyway when we get back to the
ants what we've got is an obligate
relationship and that obligate
relationship is clearly
great for the ants and it is you know
clearly great for the fungus in fact
it's so great that both of them have
evolved to become completely dependent
on it and so at this point there's no
point in looking at the relationship and
saying who's you know who who's driving
they're both driving right
um but it doesn't mean if you traced it
back far enough you would almost
certainly find a parasitism that turned
out to have a benefit for the victim and
therefore a mutualism Grew From it and
you know
is it is
statistically very unlikely that two
clades two individuals to any things
coming together
that end up in a Cooperative romantic
what you know whatever it is
relationship
have exactly the same moment of hey here
it is this is this is what we're going
to do right so almost always and we can
basically say really almost almost
always if not always
one of those individuals or claims or
entities will have made a move first
will have had an advantage first will
have seen the opportunity first right
and it this is I was actually having a
parallel thought actually
um the way to see this clearly is the
Romantic analog of this right because a
you can see that individuals are
motivated to get involved romantically
by a very powerful kind of self-interest
which is so powerful that it uh
predisposes them to a kind of mutualism
but the
let's take the case of uh
to randos right considering whether to
get romantically involved right you
think it sounds so awesome uh yeah I'm
trying I'm trying to uh to not impose
anything one way or the other on it
um a guy
uh trying to bed a gal is actually
involved in a parasitic Behavior now in
modern times it may not be this way
because it may be that he you know his
conscious mind full well understands
that she is going to control whether or
not she gets pregnant and so there's no
real parasitism possible at that level
but a guy trying to bet a gal pre
um uh birth control right is effectively
attempting to inflict a pregnancy on
somebody who will then invest all of the
labor in raising an offspring that is
only 50 related to her that's parasitism
right however the possibility of a
relationship that is reproductive and
worthy of both Partners right the point
is that would be parasitism is adjacent
to a obvious profound mutualism in which
two people decide to team up on the
raising of Offspring and the creation of
a home and all of those things and you
know we sometimes hear people almost
jokingly talk about the
um
a fetus being a parasite on the mother
which is not correct but it is actually
half correct in the case that the father
has not stuck around right because the
female has been put in the position of
raising an offspring you know she's
divided her genome in half
fused it with a half a genome from
somebody else and if that guy skips out
then the point is the half the genome
that isn't related to her that she is
raising that is uh she is effectively in
forced into a degree of altruism raising
this other half a genome but if they
partner then it is not bad at all right
then the point is yes she's only you
know her Offspring is only 50 related to
her but
um the guy is putting in enough effort
that the point is she can actually raise
twice as many as many of them and she
recovers that as As a matter of a
mutualism so anyway now we've taken all
the fun out of uh sex romance uh and all
of that stuff but the idea that there is
an exact map
of this sort of tension between
parasitism and mutualism over in human
romantic space is it's really profound
once you see it
indeed I thought you were going to go
into genomic imprinting space but maybe
that's that's a bridge too far for today
yeah I think I think uh you've done
enough enough of the drive sucking the
fun out of romance biology for uh for
one afternoon but maybe a future episode
all right
um so
we thought we'd start there just to
raise issues of raised Consciousness
questions of when you see interactions
uh between two players let's say let's
just leave it vague entities uh who
appears to be control who appears to be
driving who appears to be conscious who
appears to be making decisions that
benefit them isn't it's not always what
it seems and that is in service of what
you wanted to talk about uh next around
issues of narrative control yep so I
wanted to add one more thing which I
think is a good transition not always
what it seems right
in the case of ants right the Queen the
queen is named as if she is the boss of
everybody else and it's not obvious that
that was actually a proper description
yes the colony is acting in service of
the queen but in some sense she is as
much a slave of the colony as she is its
director she is not actually in a
position
to dictate what the ants do it is this
underlying uh genetic fact of their
close relatedness that causes them to
behave in such a way that this queen who
is totally hobbled by her she's just an
Egg Factory yeah she's just producing
mostly mostly daughters some some Sons
but mostly daughters all of whom are
more closely related to each other than
they are with their mom if they're full
sibs and uh she's just pumping out eggs
when they're fertilized their daughters
when they're not fertilized their sons
and and it's just that's that's what
she's doing and you can get a totally
wrong idea in fact I had the
um once in a lifetime pleasure of
watching a uh a colony of these um these
ants these farming ants move from one uh
one burrow to another and probably that
was a result of the fact that something
had gotten in and they needed to move
and to escape a parasite but I watched
them uh Hubert uh hubby who was on BCI
when I was there studying leafcutter
ants
knew that the move was happening and he
and I went and uh
filmed it but anyway the point was the
queen was being moved right we saw the
queen being moved B
was so distorted by her reproductive
role she couldn't even walk right she
was literally being carried and you can
imagine that early you know scientific
appreciators of these ants might look at
it's like a queen and a litter being
escorted to her new uh her new
um Nest but that's really that's a
projection of a human construct that is
really not very similar right
she is a reproductive slave of the
colony as much as anything else so
which then brings us to your transition
about things not being necessarily what
they seem and the confusions surrounding
um uh corruption and narrative control
in uh in our modern modern circumstance
[Music]